hey david you talked about right-wing dog
whistles are there left-wing dog whistles
this is an interesting question remi you know
when we talk about a dog whistle a dog whistle
is a coded message that's communicated by using
words or phrases or even gestures in some way
that are commonly understood by a particular group
of people and not necessarily by others so as an
example a george soros and roth the rothschilds
that has become a dog whistle for anti-semitic
tropes about rich usually jewish men conspiring
to control elements of government or banking
or whatever the case may be the recent marjorie
taylor green jewish space laser incident when she
says the rothschilds that is a dog whistle for
people who are primed about uh jewish conspiracies
to control this or that industry to understand
that by rothschilds you're really talking about
jews george soros often when it's mentioned
it means jews and so that would be example of
a right-wing dog whistle people some people are
attuned to listen to it listen for it or to hear
it globalist is another one which often also
is used to signal we're talking about jews now
i have some examples of left wing maybe what we
would call dog whistles they're pretty lame and
they really don't rise to the level of the right
wing dog whistles the right uses dog whistles much
more than the left here's a couple of examples i
could think of sometimes when the left says rural
you could argue that it's a sort of dog whistle
for like the uneducated hillbilly meme or
caricature sometimes not not always um sometimes
there's dog whistling around suggesting people are
racist like for example saying someone voted for
the crime bill talking about the 90s crime bill
that could be a pseudo dog whistle to imply
someone is is racist without saying this is
a racist person um maybe flyover country is a
dog whistle to suggest that you know kind of the
center of the country is less than the so-called
liberal coastal areas the reason that these are
kind of weak is because the left really doesn't
use language in the dog whistle way that the right
does for better or worse and when i say for worse
we know that the left is terrible at branding
and to some degree even though the dog whistling
on the right is disgusting in many cases including
stuff like soros as a catch-all for for jews some
of the dog whistling the right does has been very
effective politically when it comes to um uh
abortion when it comes to some religious ideas
when it comes to taxation there are dog whistles
that the right has used successfully i think
they're disgusting and inaccurate they relate to
socialism and life and all these different things
but the reason that the examples i'm coming up
with for the left uh um the reason that those
are lame uh is that the left really just doesn't
use language in this way and to some degree the
left has suffered for it the left has probably
lost what could have been wins in some cases
because their branding and language is is not as
uh finely tuned finally operating of a machine
as the writers if you can think of left-wing dog
whistles that i've missed certainly let me know
we've got a fantastic bonus show for you
today get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com